[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais je reviens du ski la ggt à
courre ch à à courchevel pour ceux qui
sont exonérés d'impôt sur le revenu au
départ moi je voulais aller à sotchi
mais en ce moment c'est pas évident de
trouver des habits de plage c'est pas
j'irai peut-être un pack pour la fée
mais n'ai rien
fait mais leiria cc comme une corrida
mais avec des feymen à la place des
terreaux
voilà c'est vrai
c'est sais
c'est que c'est une beauté très russe tu
vois c'est surtout lorsque le film et
norwich passé le toréador kozak il ya
fait il agite une casserole et dans un
mouvement d'une classe folle tu vois il
doit toucher le nichon avec une spatule
en bois ceir et juste à ce moment là en
général la semaine s'incline on lui
donne la casserole et la spatule et là
elle doit faire un aligot pour toute la
reine
csu c'est super bon donc à défaut de
sotchi je me suis dit bon pourquoi pas
courchevel c'est ça ressemble un peu et
autant de russes mais a plus de neige
donc
alors je sais que c'est un peu un
délicat de parler de ça devant des gens
qui ont peut-être jamais au ski et mais
non mais faut pas se raconter
d'histoires c'est tout n'est pas
idyllique
surtout quand on est c'est quand est
bloqué à l'aéroport de chambéry fait pas
assez beau pour que l'hélico d'école
alors tu apprends de la cayenne pour
monter face et je le souhaite à personne
une fois sur place c'est que des ennuis
sur les pistes des files d'attentes les
gens qui passent devant avec une langue
étrangère le truc qui ferme à 16h30 moi
j'ai l'impression d'être à la cave son
chauffage tu vois
après les soirs tu dis bon je vais mort
mais je vais faire une petite sortie
comme ça alors il ya des russes m'ont
invité à une fondue super sympa et super
c on a joué un jeu c'est celui qui fait
tomber sa rolex dans la fondue trois
fois un gage
mon 24 carats égaré dans du fromage qui
pue c'est pas top quand tu retires 24
carats d'une fondue c'est à peu près ce
que doit ressentir le douanier quand il
saisit un paquet de coke dans le cul
d'une mule ça doit être un peu
sinon quoi d'autre alors cette semaine
j'ai décidé de faire fi de la politique
puisque municipal oblige on n'a pas le
droit de parler politique française quel
soulagement
comme si c'était un truc intéressant
et jason c'est dur de ne pas parler de
politique surtout ces municipales c'est
demain ça commence devant et d'ailleurs
comme disait jean michel aphatie notre
représentante de la diversité cassoulet
notre sorte de mouloud achour du gers
pourquoi ne pas faire un peu de
politique fiction voire même de la
politique qu'ils ont l'air tout d'abord
est ce que les électeurs vont faire de
cette élection un message cantonales
nationales internationales au front
national
mais dans la mesure où tout se tient car
les opposés s'attirent et qu'une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps elle
ne fait pas l'automne ni même l'hiver
mais [ __ ] qu'est ce qui me rend le
lire on est là
[Applaudissements]
on va scruter ce qu'il se passe dans les
mégalopoles mais qu'elle est
mais brignoles le pays et hénin beaumont
les poumons économiques donc dépendre
directement notre bonheur des
exportations bien entendu alors comme à
chaque élection on va nous dire circulez
rien à voir tout va se jouer sur la
météo il fait beau les gens ne votent
pas il fait mauvais ce vote alors intox
ou mensonge
bien malin qui pourra résumer ce que je
viens de dire et prédire ce qui va
arriver bien qu'une seule certitude il
est fort à parier que le 23 mars grand
vainqueur du scrutin sera le bélier
puisqu'on entre dans sa constellation
qui dit bélier dix cornes et croyez moi
il y aura beaucoup de cocu
c'est donc ça avoir honte ainsi génial
musique madonna ne supporte pas
d'écouter sa propre musique devrait au
moins le faire pendant les
enregistrements il nous aurait pas renié
quatre albums forcément
médecine en ce moment je sais mais chez
les médecins sa salive il ya un
cardiologue un ostéo un gynéco tous mis
en examen pour viol c'est un peu sévère
pour une fois que quelqu'un a envie de
se taper un malade
bon le cardiologue été mis en examen
pour viol lui devrait s'en sortir parce
qu'il a plaidé la dyslexie il a confondu
valvules
[Applaudissements]
sécurité police nationale
trois voitures de police poursuivent un
voleur résultat dix personnes blessées
dont neuf policiers
c'est avec ce genre d'infos que tu
comprends que la sécurité à marseille
c'est pas gagné
sentiments pour ses 23 ans une jeune
femme a décidé de faire l'amour avec 23
mai quand même temps ouais je dis bien
faire l'amour parce que il y aura des
bougies et les mecs m'ont porté des
masques donc ça va être plutôt beau ça
pas être glauque du tout après c'est
peut-être pas l'idée du siècle quoi vu
l'état du corps féminin à 70 ans elle
aurait peut-être mieux fait de répartir
l'effort quoi
bah oui bonne nouvelle facebook
maintiendra public les profils
d'utilisateurs décédé c'est chouette
quelle classe tu auras pour épitaphe une
invitation à jouer à caen dick roche
alors être à beloeil et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus